protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News you're watching
smite on the show this week help me
obi-wan Kenobi a hologram finally going
to be part of our everyday lives
battle of the bricks the new Lego game
taking on minecraft and for duke ins and
sonic booms for everyone
street fighter comes to ps4 in our game
jerseys hello and welcome to swine now
if you're a fan of sci-fi movies you've
probably been waiting for years for
futuristic technology to become
mainstream jetpacks hoverboards and
lightsabers might not be coming to a
home anytime soon but Holograms may be
here's Stewart
on how technology is blurring the lines
between the digital and the real we've
seen augmented reality and Holograms in
science fiction for years but the kind
of technology that bridges the physical
and digital worlds could soon be a part
of our everyday lives
take these augmented reality glasses
from meta in California that could help
you with introductions and networking be
used as a teaching aid or even allow you
to play games in your house or office
are incredibly important for creation
and our minute reality is uniquely
uniquely suited to bring people together
meta has competition from microsoft's
hololens an invention which has prompted
the company to say if it's turning
science fiction into in their words
science fact if this is the road between
physical and digital it's a two-way
street
while the computer-generated world
bleeds into the real there are also
plans for the opposite googles project
tango wants our devices to be able to
learn the real world in the same way
humans learn to navigate new buildings
or areas and the team at scan lab do
large-scale 3d scanning to make digital
replicas of buildings landscapes or
objects they've recently captured a
model of a hidden underground railway in
London called the male rail preserving
it in its abandoned state the precision
and the amount of information we're
recording is sort of unparalleled in
many cases so we're able to see leaves
on trees blades of grass it can be used
by the police to scan crime scenes and
road accidents it can be used by fire
brigade or it can be used by surveyors
it's a way of documenting space not all
of this technology is limited to big
companies some of it is available in
your home right now take HP's new
desktop computer sprout which allows you
to scan objects into your computer in 2d
or 3d the digital worlds are colliding
the more and more that that those
wearable technologies those different
display technologies that can inject
digital content onto the world around us
the more you can imagine taking all of
the knowledge of the cloud and injecting
it on to this world around us so one of
the items you saw in Stuart's piece
there was the HP sprout we've come along
to get a closer look at it and joining
us is Stuart mark tech expert Stuart
this is desktop computing of a
completely different kind isn't it it is
they've basically decided to bypass some
of the need for the keyboard a mouse and
giving you a 3d sort of scanning area
where you can either create 2d or 3d
scans as well as what sort of things so
what kind of stuff can it do so let's
show you an example so we're going to
capture this is pretty rose and some
butterflies they're just put that there
and I press the capture button what it
does is it takes a picture of this and
if you see it's those images once I save
those files I can then manipulate those
images how I see fit those are too close
together that wall and there's a 3d
element too there is so if we go back
here and go
3d element now if you put your hand do
this that's probably a good thing I
press here now this takes about 17
seconds to capture and it will fire
loads of different lights at you to
capture can I take my hand you can take
your hand off so let's just do a quick
cleanup of some of the stuff that I
captured I'll say yes and then now if we
can now rotate and you've got your hand
you see is this just pcs way of trying
to pull one back from the mobile market
I think it's about trying to offer a
different set of creative tool so you
wouldn't necessarily see on on a tablet
with tablets we've got stuff that like
project tango from Google which is
mostly about scanning rooms there's lots
of different ways of inputting we're
finding that a lot of the moment where
there's lots of different ways of using
these tools and in new ways than we have
previously and I think that's probably a
good thing I think some people it's a
very niche market but I think some
people will find this really useful and
completely change the way they work and
other people will find it very much a
gimmick you're watching flight coming up
tape splat Nintendo's new
family-friendly shoot them up in our
games release but first here's a roundup
of some of this week's other tech news
it looks like the uber popular minecraft
has a rival after Lego launched its new
video game lego worlds is available now
but a final release is set for next year
when it will include extras and
improvements based on gamers feedback
Warner Brothers says future plans
include multiplayer and sharing features
a company in Perth Australia is trying
to combine the concepts of smartphone
and Smart Watch Blu uses a flexible LED
display allowing you to wrap your phone
around your wrist they call it a
wearable smartphone the device currently
being funded on IndieGoGo is about two
times longer than your typical phone the
latest edition of Microsoft Windows has
been given a release date Windows 10
will be available from the 29th of July
and those who already use newer versions
of the software will get it as a free
download Microsoft has skipped the
number nine in the naming of its
operating systems jumping straight from
eight to ten the us-born app to get
last-minute theater tickets has arrived
in the UK today ticks which was set up
by two Broadway producers in New York is
free and aims to get you the best prices
on last-minute tickets for shows in New
York and now London's West End the
company says it saved customers four
point seven million dollars on tickets
shoot-'em-ups are pretty gory and
disturbingly realistic these days but
one of the titles in our games review
this week is a family-friendly shooter
and their octopuses - here's Mark Ultra
Street Fighter 4 is an update to a game
that's been around a long time the
Street Fighter series it's quite a
history to it and this is a version of
the game that was released last year on
the Xbox 360 and PlayStation 3 but now
it's on the PlayStation 4 and basically
it's a fighting game and beauty of
fighting games
easy to pick up and play so if you learn
how to kick and punch using specific
buttons on the gamepad or an arcade
stick and try and perform combos to beat
your opponent the only issue with the
PlayStation 4 version right now is that
there are a few little bugs in the game
that they're hoping to sort out so I'd
say you know check it out
but maybe wait a couple weeks until they
sort out those final bugs
so here's of the storm is a multiplayer
online battle arena game otherwise known
as a MOBA now for the uninitiated this
is quite a deep set of games primarily
led by a game called League of Legends
this is blizzards take on that genre of
games and essentially it's a 5v5 battle
arena game where you team up with other
players online it's free-to-play and the
idea is it's sort of a mix of strategy
and an action and you've you basically
go through the game trying to defeat
your opponents part of the reason this
game is doing so well
having just launched is that people can
get into it very very easily so this one
is worth checking out that said you know
some people sort of lamenting the fact
that you know perhaps is a bit too
casual but I think the accessibility
more than makes up for it so splatoon is
an interesting game because this is a
game from Nintendo traditionally known
for Mario and Zelda and games like that
quite family-friendly games but splatoon
is its take on a shooter instead of
trying to you know kill people or or
shoot people the aim of the game is to
paint things so you have two teams of
4v4 and the idea is is that each team
has to paint as much of the map as
possible with bright garish colors some
of the weapons in the game are like
rollers that allow you to paint paths
because you play as a character that can
transform into a squid the best thing
about splatoon is just that for that
three-minute burst of playing a game
online with other people it nails it
more than I think perhaps any other
shooter does so if you're after
something that is not violent at all in
the slightest is super colorful is super
fun something that you can play with the
entire family
and I would absolutely check out spittle
that's it for this week but don't forget
you can stay up to date with all the
latest tech story guy needs for iPad our
smartphone app sky news calm and our
YouTube channel we'll see you again next
week bye bye
protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News